[Music]
now that's how you get the party started
Bad Bunny opening the 2023 Grammys with
a high energy mashup of Ella pahon and
desqueza La Plaza and turning LA's
crypto.com Arena into a dance fest with
dancers wearing paper mache heads and
colorful skirts getting down on stage
and in the aisles where famous fans like
Taylor Swift got in on the action
jacarlo was also feeling good I'm very
grateful that the world uh can connect
with my music even when I in Singing in
my language Spanish a lot of people
don't don't speak Spanish but love my
music so I'm very grateful for that when
it comes to his performance look bad
bunny made a fresh white tea light
washed jeans and a clean pair of white
sneaks Look fashion forward you're a
fashion icon you have the best game when
it comes to your clothes I gotta tell
you thank you thank you the Latin trap
star has a lot to be grateful for
gracias
this is really easy when you do things
with love and passion everything is
easier the life is easier his latest
album um veranos and teaser he is the
first Spanish language album to ever
receive a Grammy nomination for album of
the year
I always
put my my a piece of my heart on
everything that I do
[Music]
thank you